اما سعاده وزير الدوله بوزاره الخارجيه
الدكتور محمد بن عبد العزيز بن صالح
الخيفي فالتقى يوم الثلاثاء الس 16 عشر من
يناير المبعوث الخاص لمستشار النمسه سعاده
السيد بيتر لونسكي تفن ثال
وسعاده السيد مارك بايسن ريتشردسن مبعوث
وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه للشؤون
الانسانيه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله ويوم الجمعه التقى بسعاده السيد
جان ايف لوديان مبعوث الرئيس الفرنسي
للبنان وسعاده السييد كريج ماكل شان الذي
سيلتقي به يوم الاربعاء القادم نائب وزير
الامن الدولي والمجموعه القانونيه
والقنصليه في وزاره الخارجيه والتجاره
الاستراليه على مستوى البيانات اصدر دوله
قطر بيانا يوم الخميس الثام عشر من يناير
يدعو ايران وباكستان الى ضبط النفس وحل
خلافاتهما عبر الحوار لا يخفى عليكم طبعا
التصعيد الذي كان بين الدولتين الشقيقتين
وبناء على ذلك صدر هذا البيان ونحن نرحب
طبعا بجميع جهود خفض التصعيد
وتجنب اي اي تبعات غير محتمله
غير مستحبه لذلك وبناء على ذلك التطورات
الايجابيه التي سمعنا عنها هي بلا شك محط
ترحيب من قبل دوله قطر هذا ما لدينا هذا
الاسبوع عنك مجال لكم سليمان حاج ابراهيم
القدس العربي شكرا لك دكتور السؤال الاول
يتعلق بتطورات الاوضاع في غزه يعني حاليا
لم نعود نسمع كثيرا عن اي جهد او اختراق
في موضوع ايقاف الحرب او حتى التوسط لاي
هدنه جديده او يعني التفاصيل مبشره بخصوص
ما يحدث في غزه هل هناك تراجع من احد
الطرفين تحديدا السلطات الاسرائيليه التي
في كل يوم تصعد من مواقفها المتشدده
واعلانها انه لن تكون هناك دوله فلسطينيه
مثلا هذا بالنسبه للسؤال الاول السؤال
الثاني تطورات الوضع ايضا في البحر الاحمر
هل هناك جهود قطريه في هذا المجال
لتخفيف حده التدخلات
العسكريه مثلا امريكا اعلنت عن تدخل
بريطانيا يعني نرى هناك استقطاب عسكري
كبير ل للبحر طيب اولا سليمان بالنسبه
لجهود الوساطه حاليا فهي ما زالت جاريه
قطر لم تتوقف منذ اليوم الاول كما اقول
لكم كل اسبوع عن كل الفرص او استغلال كل
الفرص الممكنه لتبادل وجهات النظر وللوصول
الى حلول بالتواصل مع طرفي النزاع وال
الاطراف الاقليميه والدوليه المختلفه وهذا
الامر ما زال على ما هو عليه وبالتالي
الجهود القطريه مستمره نحن نسمع طبعا
ونقرا معكم الكثير من التقارير الاعلاميه
حول هذه الجهود ما نشدد عليه ان يتم اخذ
هذه المعلومات من مصادرها الرئيسيه من هنا
ومن الاطراف المعنيه لان حقيقه كثير من
هذه المعلومات هي معلومات مغلوطه او
منقوصه او غير متوافقه مع اخر التحديثات
فيما يتعلق بجهود الوساطه ولكن هذه جود
مستمره بين الطرفين نحن نبقى دائما في
حاله تفاؤل بان تؤدي هذه الجهود الى نجاح
وكنا اكدنا على لسان عدد من المسؤولين
خلال الفتره الماضيه بان جهود الوساطه
الجاريه الان لن تتوقف ايا كانت الظروف
على الارض وهذا هو ما نستمر به الان
بالنسبه لتطورات الوضع في البحر الاحمر
كما سمعتم معالي رئيس م الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه في دافوس قال بوضوح ان هذا يمثل
خطر كبير بالنسبه للاقليم بشكل عام ولكن
لن يكون حله حلا عسكريا ولذلك نحن ندعم
جميع الجهود الاقليميه لخفض التصعيد في
هذا الاطار ولكن نؤكد مره اخرى على ان هذه
المساله بدات بالتصعيد في في الاراضي
المحتله وبالتالي ستنتهي بانهاء التصعيد
في الاراضي المحتله وعلى راس ذلك طبعا
ايقاف الحرب
هناك
احمد رئيس الوزراء معلي رئيس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطري ذكر في مؤتمر تافس ان
على المحيط العربي
الاقليمي تقريب وجهات النظر بينهم
وبين بينهم وبين ايران الرئيس الايراني
سيزور الدوحه الاثنين القادم ما هو
التقارب القطري الايراني الذي يحدث فيما
يتعلق بحرب قزه وفي البحر الاحمر ايضا
شكرا شكرا احمد طبعا لا شك ان الموقف
القطري من
مساله التصعيد في في المنطقه بشكل عام هو
مستمر على وضعه ومستمر بنفس المواقف
السابقه اول
نحن كنا دائما نقول ومثل ما تفضلت احمد
اكد معالي رئيس مجس وزراء وزير الخارجيه
ذلك في تصريحاته في خلال الجلسه في في
دابس بان الطريق الامثل للتعامل مع
الخلافات مع ايران هو عبر الحوار ولن يتم
ذلك الا عب عبر منظومه اقليميه في التعامل
مع هذا الحوار وهذا هو الامر الذي نراه
الان يحدث نحن رحبنا بكل المبادرات لخفض
التصعيد في في المنطقه في اطار التواصل مع
ايران من ضمن ذلك طبعا الوساطه الصينيه
بين ايران التي ادت الى الاتفاق بين ايران
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه وكذلك
المفاوضات حول ما يجري في اليمن المفاوضات
حول ما يجري في لبنان وتقريب وجهات النظر
هناك كل هذا طبعا ياتي في اطار الموقف
القطري الداعم للحوار في اطار خفض التصعيد
العديد من المسؤولين الايرانيين زاروا
الدوله خلال الفتره الماضيه خاصه وزير
الخارجيه الايراني وهذه الزياره بلا شك
انها تاتي في اطار اولا العلاقات الثنائيه
وتنميتها سواء على مستوى الاقتصادي او او
الجوانب الاخرى ولكن ايضا لا شك ان موضوع
غزه والحرب في غزه يحتل الاولويه في كل
لقاءاتنا الثنائيه حقيقه هذه الايام مع كل
الاطراف ولا شك لدي ان هذا سيعكس ذات
الاتجاه
ولكن المهم ان يكون هناك حقيقه حوار في
المنطقه وهذا الحوار يستدعي جميع القضايا
ذات الاهتمام لجميع الاطراف ويضع مخاوف كل
الاطراف على الطاوله ويضع الملفات بشكل
واضح وشفاف وقطر كانت وما زالت ترى ان هذا
هو السبيل الوحيد للتعامل مع مع ازمات
المنطقه المختلفه